I oh look with the Cat Dragged In good
afternoon
eileene how's your day Dad it was a day
just another day my day was a doozy it's
one of those days you never
forget listen up this young lady is our
new prison
psychologist she may be easy on the eyes
but I assure you she is very
smart I'm Rebecca I
know I don't think I caught your
[Music]
name
oopsie nasty habit that's why I like it
I live a little differently than most
people they probably scared
you prison is no place for a young lady
you got a big life ahead of you I'm sure
I'm just kind of average I think you
really think you're a normal
person I bet you have brilliant
dreams alen may I confide in you people
are so ashamed of their
desires I have my own
ideas kind
ideas you can never tell anyone do you
understand promise me okay
that will make you
crazy that will make you
[Music]
kill can imagine you with a knife can
you imagine me with a
gun that's very good E Yeah I can see
it you're different these days it's
almost interesting secrets and lies some
things are so twist
the only way I ask for someone to
die that was a great
trick